time for the Continental Tire coaches
corner is Brian Kelly Notre Dame head
coach and last game they beat North
Carolina coming up tomorrow night at
7:30
they got USC coming to town coach thanks
for joining us how much NFL do you watch
very little I mean Sunday's when we're
in here breaking down film I'll have it
on it's kind of the backdrop but I don't
get a chance really to focus much on the
NFL do you think the NFL borrows more
from college than college borrows from
the NFL you know I think it really
depends in certain situations you know I
think the quarterback situation as it is
right now requires some of the NFL teams
to borrow some of the college schemes to
fit the quarterback but but I would say
for the most part the NFL has a system
of offense and defensive structure that
they they follow closely with and have
been for for a number of years I'd say
that the change though Dan is probably
trying to fit some of the offenses to
the you know the quarterbacks that are
coming out
speaking of quarterbacks the difference
between Sam Darnell this year from what
you've seen as opposed to last year's
what you know he's a similar player I
think you know a second year in the
offense trying to do a lot and sometimes
they get you into a little bit of a
problem with trying to force some things
but he's as advertised in terms of the
ability to get the ball out of his hands
athleticism you know he has all the
traits maybe trying to do a little bit
too much sometimes and and again
probably the fishbowl effect right you
know you know everybody's got eyes on
I'm trying to make some plays young guy
but just a terrifically talented player
you made a name for yourself as being an
offensive minded guy not being afraid to
open it up throw the football now I got
a defensive minded team and a running
football team how did this happen well
you know I think you needed to put sense
to who we were going to recruit here at
Notre Dame and that was that we were
going to get physical players offensive
linemen that really you know I think
lended itself to a more physical style
of football and you know it doesn't mean
you can't throw the football it doesn't
mean you have to be balanced I mean
there's no question about that and
whatever you do but I think it just
lended itself to a more physical kind of
football team and so what about making
those philosophical changes and we had
the pieces here already it just made
sense to move in that direction I don't
know if you're enjoying yourself more
this year it feels like that but are you
I am I really am I think you know
freeing me up in terms of not having to
be you know creating offensive structure
and you know being in those type of
meetings and being more around the
players it's really why you do this is
the relationships that you build with
the players and that's fun I mean look
they're 18 to 21 year olds it makes you
young and and getting a chance to to you
know see them develop again that's why
you would do this that's why you put in
70 80 hours a week and and I think that
that's really energizing and you're
dancing in the locker room I wouldn't
call it dancing what's your wife
Paulette there's some words I can't use
I will say this you know when you're
around young guys it's it's like I said
I think you you feel as though you're
more part of it and you get excited with
them and and it's fun the absent
professor comment that you said you were
last year how did you get in that
position where you were the absent
professor well I think
you know again it's always you know
about how you choose your words at the
time that you're talking you know with
whomever I was talking with I just felt
like a bit detached from our football
team and that I didn't prepare them
mentally well enough to win close games
and we lost seven games by a possession
last year and I really had made my
entire career on winning those close
games so I just felt like I have been
detached from our team and not close
enough to him to help them through those
close games and I had to reevaluate
you know how I went to work every day
and part of that evaluation process is
that I needed to be closer to our team I
needed to spend more time with them to
help build that that mental toughness
necessary to win close games
he's Brian Kelly joining us Continental
Tire coaches corner Notre Dame USC
coming up tomorrow night
is it still beneficial to be independent
as I look at that second half of the
schedule here coach you got a brutal run
coming up man
yeah certainly you know we still love
the ability to play the kind of schedule
we play and it's a difficult schedule
but it still has to stand up to teams
that are gonna play 13 games with the
conference championship so it's going to
be rigorous and it has to be and and
we've got to win all of our games and so
you know our challenge here is there is
no conference championship so you're
playing for a national championship or
what are you playing for so your
schedule has to look that way and that's
that's what the trade-off is of being
independent so our guys know that when
they come to Notre Dame we know that
going into the season so we embrace it
and we look at it as a positive coming
in you know the pressure is there
obviously I don't have to spell those
out but did you ever think that your job
could have been in jeopardy following
last season oh I think at Notre Dame
there's a standard and I didn't live up
to the standard and when you don't live
up to a standard of play here at Notre
Dame you're going to be screwed
nice for that and you're going to be
evaluated as such and but I think not
only at Notre Dame but you know there's
probably you know a dozen schools that
you know fall under that same category
that if we don't live up to that
standard of play you know you're going
to be evaluated as such and Notre Dame
is in that same boat in terms of you
know we want to develop our players we
want to graduate all of our players we
want to play four championships but
there's still a standard of play and we
didn't live up to that standard and and
you know to get the scrutiny that I did
it was certainly deserving if you rushed
for 300 yards tomorrow night finish that
sentence if we rushed for 300 yards and
take care of the football we'll win the
football game okay well you've been
doing that so far and the defense has
been getting some takeaways here but
this is a little bit different with with
USC there oh yeah yeah yeah I mean look
this is a game where you know for me you
know this is an incredibly dynamic
offense they look I've watched enough of
USC over the years you know having
played them they've had great players
they still have great players you know
you've got to be able to slow them down
and we got to keep 14 off the field
Sam darling and and so 300 yards rushing
would be awesome but you're right there
are other factors that have to come into
this game as well and you know we're
gonna have to play up to the level that
we have defensively and Mykel goes done
a great job taking the football away and
playing good defense so it's gonna be
fun USC Notre Dame playing you know a
game that really means something at this
time of the year you know I think it's
it's good TV did you recruit Sam Darnell
no we did not I mean we knew about Sam
but you know he was playing you know
quarterback and he was playing a little
bit of tight end and a little bit of
both but we had already made a decision
on a quarterback but knew of him and
what kind of really good athlete he was
yeah I know coaches hate this like how
did you miss on that guy like everybody
else in the country missed on this guy
that you know it but you knew about him
but you weren't quite sure what kind of
quarterback he was going to be no he was
at a couple of camps that you know
obviously you get evaluation at camps I
know Brandon Wimbush and him were at
Camp together out on the west coast and
and you know you get evaluations and you
know this big athletic kid who's Raw's
it was kind of the the evaluation and
and he wasn't been under recruited
because he was not playing full-time at
quarterback out of high school at Santa
Margarita and then obviously comes in
and and certainly was you know more than
advertised and he's gotten everything
that he's deserved he's he's I think
he's the best quarterback in college
football
have some fun tomorrow night okay we
will and you know obviously I know you
probably got a little wager going with
with your producer so obviously this
will be a fun one - all right well thank
you that's a brian kelly notre dame head
coach continental tire coaches corner
from sunday rain to snow and everything
in between continental tire is engineer
to tire for what you do and love these
people extraordinary performance and
reliability putting confidence into
driving for more info and the location
of a dealer near you visit Continental
Tire comm cutting home tire for what you
do for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]